aquí tenemos una lista de 15 números y
en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre los
números atípicos y para ayudarnos a
hacer esto vamos a visualizar cuál es la
distribución de estos números vamos a
hacer esto aquí tengo una recta numérica
con los números desde el 1 hasta el 19
veamos tenemos 2 unos aquí hay un 1 y
aquí hay otro 1 tenemos un 6
tenemos 2 números 13 aquí hay un 13 y
aquí otro 13 tenemos 3 números 14
14 14 y 14 tenemos 2 números 15 15 y 15
tenemos un 16 tenemos tres números 18 1
2 3 y por último tenemos un 19 cuando
vemos la distribución de números
gráficamente parece que la parte
principal de la distribución se
encuentra en esta área y quizá algunas
personas digan bueno tenemos tres
cantidades atípicas estos dos 1 2 y el 6
quizá otras personas digan bueno el 6 no
está tan alejado de estos así que quizás
solo estos 2 unos son los atípicos y
ambos argumentos son cosas razonables
pero para llegar a un acuerdo los
especialistas en estadística a veces
usan una regla que dice que cualquier
cosa que sea por debajo de 1 o por
encima de q 31.5 por el rango inter
cuartil serán los números atípicos
a qué me refiero con todo esto vamos a
encontrar la mediana y acunó y a q3
después encontraremos el rango inter
cuartil y ahora sí usando esa definición
podremos encontrar los números atípicos
y si todo esto tiene sentido para
ustedes los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta si no lo vamos a resolver juntos
ahora cuál es la mediana aquí la mediana
es el número de enmedio tenemos 15
números así que el número de enmedio va
a ser cualquier número que tenga 7
números a ambos lados 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
esta es la mediana también conocida como
q 2 ahora cuál es con 11 va a ser el
número que está en medio de este grupo
este primer grupo tiene 7 números en él
así que el número de enmedio será el
cuarto número tendrá tres números a la
derecha y tres números a su izquierda
así que aquí tenemos aquí
q 3 va a ser el número de en medio de
este grupo de aquí que también tiene 7
números por lo que el número de en medio
es este de aquí aquí tenemos a q3 y cuál
será el rango inter cuartil aquí el
rango inter cuartil va a ser igual a q 3
- con 1 la diferencia entre 18 y 13 18
menos 13 va a ser igual a 5 ahora como
vamos a encontrar los números atípicos
los números atípicos van a ser aquellos
que sean menores que q 1 menos 1.5 por
el rango inter cuartil y nuevamente esto
no es una regla del universo es
simplemente un acuerdo entre estadistas
para tener una mejor definición de los
números atípicos simplemente acordaron
que cualquier cosa que se encuentre por
debajo de 1.5 por el rango inter cuartil
restado a kuno o cualquier cosa que se
encuentre por encima de 3 más
1.5 por el rango inter cuartil es un
acuerdo en el que se establece que
cualquier cantidad que se encuentre por
debajo de 1 menos 1.5 por el rango inter
cuartil va a ser un atípico o cualquier
cantidad que se encuentre por encima de
q 3 más 1.5 por el rango inter cuartil
estos serán los números atípicos esto
simplemente es un acuerdo para decidir
qué cantidades son atípicas y cuáles no
veamos a qué se refieren estas
cantidades con 1 es 13 menos 1.5 por el
rango inter cuartil que es 5 así que es
1.5 por 5 lo que nos da 7.5 13 menos 7.5
nos da
13 menos 76 y le restamos otro punto 5 y
nos queda 5.5
o tres es 18 más 1.5 por el rango inter
cuartil que es 5 es nuevamente 7.5 18
más
7.5 nos da a 25.5 o los números atípicos
también serán aquellos que son mayores
que 25.5 con base en esto ya tenemos una
definición numérica de los números
atípicos ya no es algo subjetivo que
nosotros digamos bueno yo creo que este
sí es atípico o yo creo que este no es
atípico y con base en esto tenemos dos
números atípicos ya que sólo estos dos
unos son menores que 5.5 aquí está
nuestro corte este 6 apenas pudo quedar
y no tenemos ningún número atípico de el
lado más alto ahora otra cosa en la que
tenemos que pensar es en dibujar
diagramas de cajas y bigotes con base en
q1 la mediana nuestro rango de números y
pueden hacerlo tomando en cuenta los
números atípicos o sin tomar en cuenta
estos números atípicos hay dos formas en
las que podemos hacer esto y vamos a
hacer un poco de espacio
vamos a dibujar una gráfica de cajas y
bigotes de hecho vamos a dibujar dos
aquí si fuéramos a graficar un diagrama
clásico de cajas y bigotes diríamos ok
nuestra mediana es 14 lo ponemos en
ambos lugares uno está en 13 q 3 está en
18 lo hacemos en ambos lugares y ya
tenemos la parte de la caja aquí también
tengo mi caja y en ambas gráficas he
hecho exactamente lo mismo hasta el
momento si no queremos considerar los
números atípicos vemos cuál es el rango
completo aquí pues vemos que va desde 1
hasta 19 así que nuestro rango va desde
1 hasta 19 en este estamos incluyendo
todo estamos incluyendo nuestros números
atípicos pero si no queremos incluirlos
y queremos ser evidente que son atípicos
pues no los incluimos y lo que hacemos
en su lugar es que como no incluimos
nuestros números atípicos pues
comenzamos en 6 ya que está en nuestro
conjunto de datos
así que comenzamos en 6 y llegamos hasta
19 y para indicar que tenemos números
atípicos pondremos este punto aquí
nuevamente este es un diagrama de cajas
y bigotes sobre el mismo conjunto de
datos 1 sin indicar los números atípicos
y otro en donde hacemos evidente que
tenemos números atípicos